at no point have you said worried about
perhaps being killed
yeah and and i had a long chat with a
couple of underworld sources about
whether he would be the sort of chap
who would go down that route and one
source said yeah you'll probably have an
accident
someone will try to rob you except
they're not really there to rob you and
you'll get killed in the attempt but
then
all the others including this source
said now
he's not that stupid chris he's not
gonna sue me and kill me
i really think that's the one or the
other situation here you know
so i should be slightly relieved that
he's suing me i guess
are you being sued by a drug lord i am
unfortunately in criminal court um
and if convicted face up to five years
in prison
and a hefty fine and i won't be allowed
to continue my work as a journalist
so long as i am still under sentence
that seems like an intense position to
be in
uh it's an unusual position to be in
in the sense that um we get sued a lot
but i've never been sued by a
drug trafficker who's actually been
named but not yet convicted
nor indeed been arrested so
um yeah strange position to be in um
but we're still um we're still plowing
on
what are the invisibles
the invisibles chris is a name we
um we've been giving to
drug traffickers here in latin america
particularly in colombia where i
where i live um that decided a while
back that their
best protection was not a private army
but was being anonymous simply not being
on anybody's radar
and you know if you if you have a look
at the the colombian
drug world going back to pablo escobar
you know he had his army of sicarios
and then after pablo escobar we have the
paramilitaries
and they end up demobilizing more than
30 000 heavily armed fighters then of
course we've got the marxist gorillas
so there is a tradition of extreme
violence verily very heavily armed
cartel structures um in colombia and
still
today in mexico and the um
this generational this group of drug
traffickers
realized that uh they would left
leave pablo escobar to take all the heat
um
and memo phantasm actually started his
career
in the medellin cartel so he goes all
the way back he's been
he's been in the business for 30 years
um
and so he's been quietly moving
we think anything up to a hundred tons
of cocaine
over the last um three decades
living in the shadows living under pablo
escobar and then
after the paramilitaries
always operate operating initially in
and out of medellin
and simply been able to do his business
without appearing on on certainly the
public's radar although
he was on the u.s radar and colombian
police radar
but he was an informant for the dea and
that
seems to have protected him it doesn't
surprise me that
it's become a better strategy for drug
lords to not be wearing a
floral shirt and a gold embossed
ak-47 and riding around in the back of
open back trucks and building their own
jails and stuff like this
every time that you speak to someone
about the new
top 100 richest people on the planet
everybody says
yeah yeah but those are the ones whose
money we know about there's got to be
some
seedy underworld crime bosses or some
arab prince that's hidden all of his
money away there has to be some of them
also has it so i guess you know even to
someone that's
an initiate the crime world
it makes sense right that someone would
do that that they wouldn't be
quite so flash that
being unseen via stealth as opposed to
untouchable via aggression
is perhaps an even better strategy
i think also chris the the way to think
about it is
um a drug trafficker
usually starts at the coal face
and the coal face in the drug world is
is your crocodile boots is your gold
chain is your pistol
stuffed down your trousers um and of
course it's this is a very
violent unpredictable world
um and so as you advance you probably
want to get
further and further away from the coal
face
um and the other thing and this is
particularly the case with memo fantasma
is
when you earn an enormous amount of
money
that provides different challenges um
you have to be able to hide that money
you have to be able to spend that money
and so um when when i speak to
uh people that knew memo phantasma
when he was young and starting in the
coal face and those that saw the
evolution of memo phantasma they said
that you know
quite quickly after after about six or
seven years
he is beginning to wear suits and he had
a pendant for european clothing
um and he decided that he didn't want to
be in the coca fields he didn't want to
be in the drug labs
he wanted to be uh in the united states
in
spain making the deals um
and that uh
when people who had known him early met
him later
they it was hard to recognize him um
so yes you can see from a business point
of view
it makes perfect sense from a drug
trafficking
point of view it makes perfect sense and
perhaps the key
thing i think is from a survival point
of view
it makes perfect sense you want to get
away from the coal face of drug
trafficking the guns blazing
um the uh the extreme violence and narco
culture
and you want to be sitting in a
penthouse in madrid
um rather than a coca field in colombia
don't you
who is this memo fantasma guy then
what's his story
okay his real name is guillermo
acevedo and i
came across him or i came across an
alias of his
back in 2005
um where the colombian government is
negotiating with this right-wing
paramilitary army
they end up demobilizing 30 000 guys
this was
probably the most powerful cartel ever
on the planet
um and they controlled most of drug
trafficking
the government was was negotiating with
them and they all had different aliases
and they were signing
different documents as they as they
moved towards a peace process
and i was looking through uh the
signatories at one of the bottom of
these documents and there was a name i
didn't recognize and i met most of these
guys over the years
and it was sebastian colmenares and so
i'm going okay who is who is sebastian
coleman
and he never appeared when it when it
was time to demobilize
uh and the name stuck with me and i was
never able to make any progress so i
sort of put that on the back burner
um and um rather rebuked myself for not
for not
making any serious investigative
progress and then i'd also
heard of a drug trafficker kicking
around medellin where i've been living
for
more than 20 years called memo fantasma
which is will the ghost if you like
um and again you know i'd heard all you
know his name kept popping up but i'd
never been able to
to to find out who he was um
and it was a bit frustrating and again
it just kind of went on to the back
burner there's the
there are dozens and dozens of these
names that you you never really
really are able to get to grips with uh
and then in 2015
there's a newspaper article that
suggests
sebastian colmenares and memo fantasma
are the same
guy and so i get very excited um you
know there are two names that have been
gathering dust on the shelves
and they both appear to be the same guy
and so i go okay enough
we we need to get to the bottom of this
um because this guy's been
kicking around memo fantasma i'd heard
had been
had been since the days of pablo escobar
and sebastian colmenares had been
sitting at the top table with these
paramilitary drug lords
um and so began the investigation
and the perhaps the most alarming thing
chris in this world when you investigate
organized crime you rely very heavily on
security force sources you know law
enforcement
um and you know i've got a great
relationship with the dea
um same with the british nca you know
the italians
and of course the colombians um because
i've been here for so long
nobody would help me with this guy
um and so the alarm bells went off
um and uh in the end
it was a source uh an underwater
source uh that uh
was able to give me uh several things
one was
yes it's the same person yes he exists
and if you go to this reality tv show
going back a while you're gonna get
you're gonna see him um
uh and as soon as i have an image then i
could go around all my sources and go
okay is this the guy you know as
fantastic and that's what happens on the
reality show
um it's one of those where they they put
up embarrassing situations and they see
how people react
and this situation is in a is in a cafe
in bogota
where a a man begins to mistreat
uh the woman he's with and so the camera
is panning to
you know how people are going to react
to this this this show of
of you know domestic violence or
whatever and it pans to
a chap who's sitting there with two
others drinking a cup of coffee
who looks across seems totally
uninterested and goes back to his
conversation
um and this was guillermo acevedo
fantasma and what happened during this
very popular show
was a group of paramilitaries in prison
when
hey that's memo phantasma
and this message came to me um and
so i had a photo and so um
the investigation really took took uh
took a life of its own
before you had that photo what happened
when you went to your sources what were
they saying to you
they said to me yeah we've all heard of
memo fantasma yes of course there was
this guy called sebastian colmenares
yes memo fantasma was a senior drug
trafficker in the medellin cartel
yes sebastian coleman was a big
heavy hitter in the paramilitary world
but then i go well then how do i find
him and they go well i don't know
i can tell you he was a small rather
uninteresting looking guy
we didn't know what his real name was um
but you know i can tell you everything
about his criminal career that we saw
but of course it didn't help me
find the guy and get a real name
so part of the issue was that he had
hidden his own history
and was so um unbecoming
that people couldn't really remember
him or give you much information but i
imagine as well that there were other
people who might have known a little bit
more
and knew just how dangerous this guy was
so it's a combination of ignorance and
fear
on top of that he was very clever
um in the sense that he never allowed
any photos to be taken of himself
um you know being in the background of a
reality tv show broadcasting national
television
which of course he didn't know he was
going to be on you know it was one of
the hidden camera ones
he should have sued them forget suing
you memo if you're listening
if you didn't sign a release form my
friend get them sued
he did try to sue them and you now can't
find it chris
okay so um he he took your advice
um but no memo what he did was he was
never in any of the photos and you know
the paramilitaries like to dress up in
uniform when they all posed with their
guns
um and he was never there he was never
there
the other thing is um
and during my interviews with the people
who have come across him
um he's apparently pretty scary dude
uh in the sense that he is prepared to
use
surgical violence to eliminate rivals
and anybody who um threatens his
business so
uh he's quiet but extremely ruthless
um and even today um now that he's been
exposed and you know he's been named by
the colombian attorney general's office
the fact that he is still free
reinforces the terror that he has
held and everyone believes including
myself
that he has very senior people on the
payroll in the police force
uh and in the attorney general's office
and perhaps in the political world
as one of the um one of the big
detonators for this story
was that i named the colombian vice
president as a
partner in one of his money laundering
businesses
and she also sued me using exactly the
same legal tool that memo fantasma is
using today but under international
pressure
she dropped the case how did
memo get so high up in the cartel did
you find that out
yes um he uh
developed um links with mexican
cartels um he
as part of his paramilitary expansion
he took a very important part of
colombia
through blood and massacre which had
along the pacific coast which is a
perfect departure point for drug
shipments
he was one of the innovators in using
drug submarines
um and he also diversified
um the market so while everybody in
colombia was moving stuff to mexico he
was still moving stuff to mexico and he
was in bed with the beltran lever
cartel but uh for example in the
olympics held in sydney he moved
a huge consignment of drugs to to
a time with the opening of the olympics
um
he had uh he made alliances with some
with a top spanish drug trafficker and
so he's
moving um drugs all around the world
and he he controls the most important
thing in the drug trafficking world
which are the roots because the money
chris is not made in the production of
drugs so the guy who
who you know who harvests the coker and
and then
runs the cocaine laboratory sure great
business
um and even the one that's in in new
york or in london
selling the drugs again great business
so the percentage for the drug
production guys is 150
which in any business world great if
you're in the retail end of the business
you're probably making 300 profit again
brilliant
but if you're the guy that takes the
kilo of cocaine from
colombia and drops it into sydney
you are making 3 000 profit
and so this is where the real money is
this is where the huge profits are so
anyone who controls the roots
everybody wants to do business with him
and that was memo fantasma
wasn't there a situation where he
someone died high up in a cartel and he
was just
left with loads of drugs wasn't this
kind of
come to power moment well this is this
is um
um this is part of the the urban myth
um uh i think it's true and i've got
some sources said it was true but other
sources say
no so i'm not going to put my hand in
the fire for this one but the story is
that um uh he is in the united states
having just received a shipment of
cocaine
from the medellin cartel when pablo
escobar
is killed on a medellin rooftop
so the medellin cartel goes
into meltdown nobody knows what the hell
is going on
and he is sitting on a very large
shipment of cocaine he sells it
and of course he doesn't know who to
push the money back up to because
there's
chaos the medellin cartel is in chaos so
he just keeps the money
well when you're fighting for leadership
you're not calling in your debtors
quite exactly right and also i think
that um
uh so much of this stuff is in people's
heads that when people get
killed all record of their business
dealings
gets lost as well yeah quickbooks.com
doesn't have a backup
exactly exactly and you know um
uh so he returns
to colombia with a pile of cash and this
we do know
we haven't confirmed he sets up his
first small company
and he sets up his own drug laboratory
about four miles north of medellin and
he starts
processing his cocaine and using his
mexican and us
contacts to go into business for himself
why are you living where you're living
given what you're doing
for work like you're just talking about
four miles away
from this place and then you're happily
living in that region for two decades um
well first of all it's absolutely
beautiful
part of the world colombia
breathtakingly beautiful
the people are you know those that
aren't trying to sue you
are absolutely lovely
and
i think for us particularly from from a
european background
where uh you know people
moan about mortgage rates and the
weather uh
living in a place where they have real
problems and still seem to have way more
fun than us um uh it's uh
it's been for me a very rewarding life
does it have of course
its downsides and uh living in in a
in a less developed world in a world
where there is enormous amounts of
violence
of course but do you not have personal
security concerns i mean are you
constantly walking around with an armed
guard or something
no absolutely not i mean yes i have the
personal security concerns
um but i'm not walking around with the
armed guard
um we have moved our kids out of out of
colombia with the
the most um recent uh raft of threats
um what would that you have to this was
linked with memo and my wife is a
journalist as well and she had received
separate threats for
oh fantastic okay so you're getting
a pincer movement yeah exactly fantastic
um
but you um i guess you have to make a
decision either you pack up and go and
do something else
or you you stick with it and we've we've
decided
to stick with it um and
also i think chris without without you
know
beating one's chest or anything this guy
can't get away with it he cannot
sue a journalist who
has proven uh not only
his existence but his criminal record
and get away with it
i mean you just you can't you can't
you can't back down in that um and one
has to point out to the colombian
judicial system the irony
of them not issuing an arrest warrant
for memo phantasm or someone who's
already been identified by the attorney
general
and they've seized two of his properties
as well so it's not like there isn't a
case there
and then the same justice system which
is seeing him walking free
being used against a journalist to
attempt to silence him
so um yeah can't that that would that
will not stand
chris that will not stand all right so
how did he get rid of his history
because everyone
is born somewhere everyone has a history
when they come into this world
okay um he got rid of his
uh initial judicial history by
bribing two
fiscales who are prosecutors in the
prosecution service of the attorney
general's office
we have their names i haven't published
them yet
because i'm not ready for another couple
of lawsuits and these two
are now jeremy yeah baby steps
baby steps with us um they are now both
very successful defense lawyers
um so if we take them on um
i'm gonna have to be ready and my lawyer
um
has gone god do we really have to do
that right now so we're not doing that
right now
um and so these two
were in the anti-narcotics
section of the attorney general's office
and so
they were able to bury
his cases then he had
two judicial policemen
also on the payroll who were also able
to
bury or
[Music]
mislead various different investigations
around him
um and then
uh he started being an informant for the
dea
which sealed the two indictments he has
in the united states that i have not
been able to get at
um i have the name of his dea agent i
have the name
of the prosecutor that put the two cases
against him
neither have uh engaged with me despite
me ambushing them
on various different um social media and
emails
and i understand why you know it's
sealed indictments and
et cetera et cetera it's a bit
frustrating
and then what he did was somehow
um as part of this this paramilitary
peace process i mentioned before
um uh chris they got a sweetheart deal
where by all these paramilitary drug
laws if they
if they cooperated with the with the
justice system
got minimal sentences eight years no
matter what they've done
um and during this process memo's name
came up several times
and his real name was mentioned
um and i didn't know this um but what i
did do is what i put a unofficial
freedom of information request
to to this this is called peace and
justice
um and i got the the information they
had
and then when we went through and we
listened to
hundreds of hours of interviews we went
this his name it's mentioned here this
guy says his name
but it's not registered anywhere which
leads us
to suspect that he had someone in peace
and justice
who also manipulated and buried
testimony
so this guy has been everywhere
clinically he's been everywhere yeah
absolutely brilliant
he's been everywhere uh and he's managed
to
to to wipe the footsteps which
they were there it's just no one was
looking and even if you started looking
they were so well buried that you had to
listen to hundreds and hundreds of hours
and go through
hundreds and hundreds of documents to
find the nugget
that you needed so he's not just got
political contacts in colombia
he's also working with the dea which is
america and peace and justice
well the peace and justice is part of
the colombian justice system he's no
longer working with the dea but he was
yeah he was um and his
dea agent actually retired um two weeks
ago
so but what i do know is that
when i went to confront memo in madrid
he immediately contacted the dea
to go what do i do um this guy
has just appeared on my doorstep okay so
how did he stay out of jail
during his period of running drugs
um well one by ensuring that no
investigation was opened against him
or by diverting
or manipulating those so it was only in
the u.s
that they got to the point of an
indictment they never in colombia got to
a point of an indictment
um and then the u.s authorities buried
the indictment because they wanted him
out there
and they flipped him and turned him into
a source i don't think they flipped him
i think he offered
i think he's that smart that he saw
that the way to um
[Music]
to remain invisible and to stay out of
prison
was to offer his services to the one
agency
that is quite hard to bribe uh
um and that you can't mess with their
paperwork
uh it's not like you can go into the us
uh attorney general's office and start
burying manipulating and mending files
so i think he made a conscious decision
um
the other thing that's quite
extraordinary about him is um
most of the guys who have flipped um
still have to spend some time in prison
it may be a laughable sentence um
particularly when one looks at the
crimes they've committed
but they they do spend anything from you
know three to ten years in
in an american prison memo has not spent
a minute
in prison and that is either a testament
to the information he delivered
or a testament to the fact that he knows
how to play the system and i think it's
a bit of both
so he must have been contacted at some
point by the dea
i mean i i no matter how much foresight
this guy has
i can't imagine that he's just rung up
and said hi is this the dea
uh yeah by the way you're probably
looking for me so they've
perhaps contacted him and he's precluded
i think he he's reached out to them
yeah he's reached out some and it's
actually very easy to do
because there are become an
informant.com or something
no there are dozens of american lawyers
who
specialize in this
which is defending colombian drug
traffickers
so what you do is one of your mates has
been extradited or got an arrest warrant
and you go oh which american lawyer are
you going to use and you go i'm going to
use
this one and then he goes all right well
can you use that one who's already
negotiating with the dea try get a plea
deal can you say boy do you fancy a chat
with me
got you got it you got you got you how
much was he worth
at the peak of his wealth i don't know
whether the peak of his wealth is now or
whether it was back in the day
well um i can tell you what we found
which is probably a tithe of what he
really has
it's between 20 and 30 million dollars
so i would suspect that we're not that
good
and he's probably worth well over 100
million
not a bad day's work i mean crime pays
chris can i just you know say that in
his case crime
has paid at least so far um
but um we're not going to give up we're
um we're about to publish a new um
series of articles on him what happened
after the first
raft of articles was
um underworld sources just came forward
so
the day after publication on twitter
i got like a 12 page document
um sent to me which basically had all
memos family tree
and at the bottom it said if you fancy a
chat
you know i'm here and i've read all this
and i was like yeah i fancy a chat
um and uh with this particular source
i've now
registered 80 hours of interviews
um i met um i met him uh
and uh uh you know he worked with memo
for
13 years so um uh
you know we've got some really great
stuff the problem
always with this chris is all these guys
are criminals
and you can't trust a word that comes
out of their mouths so you have to
verify it
and that has been a long and exhaustive
process because i've had no help from
police or law enforcement i've had to
verify and i am having to verify it with
other
underworld sources and so when three
underworld sources say the same thing
and they're not connected
you go well actually you know what yeah
i'm i'm i'm prepared to go with that
and this particular sort yeah and this
source over the 80 hours i haven't
caught him in a single lie
yet um so he seems to be he seems to be
the real deal
this is only going to be part one in
that case oh we've
got one has been published this is going
to be part two okay yeah so we've got
i mean to the podcast we're gonna get
get ourselves up to this stage of where
we're at with
with these articles and then when the
next part comes out they can be the
the difficult sequel absolutely i hope
so and then i'm hoping that the last one
chris will be my final interview with
memo from his prison cell
okay fantastic um okay so
going back how did you get onto his
trail more seriously you've got his
photo
from the background of ashton kutcher
doing a
punk'd episode or whatever it is and
then columbian astronomy
and then you go right okay i have his
image i can show it to people people can
say yes that is him
i mean that that doesn't mean much more
either
we we found his real name in
these files from peace and justice
you know one of his partners in the
paramilitary army
says his name and the name that i was
given that they had for him was a
was a false alia it was an alias that he
used in the paramilitaries
actually that was a dead end to begin
with but then when we went through
all of the all of the the transcripts
and we heard it
then we find another name
[Music]
and with that name we are
able to start following
a money trail so there's stuff there
were businesses that were associated
with memo fantasma in particularly in
the airport
in medellin he had a hangar there
and we've been told by so many different
sources oh memo was the owner of that
but i'm going
i haven't got a name and you know i
can't go through every single hangar
and find out if that's memo fantasma but
then we got
this name from the paramilitary peace
process
and once you've got a name and you've
got the the companies
um we got his id card from the chamber
of commerce because you know when you
register a company
you have to put your id in there so they
he had to scan his id card and that was
it
we had him dead to rights after that
because then
we find he's got a legal company um
we follow the legal company because of
course the more and more successful you
become as a drug trafficker the less and
less you put under your name
for obvious reasons um and so what we
did is we find his legal company we find
the names of his relatives his wife
who's
up to her neck in it as well and then we
start following those names
and so suddenly the business begins to
move further and further and further
and this is where we found his mum
had bought a series of properties
in the most expensive part of bogota
so these were old houses uh in a
neighborhood in the north of bogota
he uses his mum and another couple of
companies to buy
almost an entire city block
he then goes to the husband of the now
vice president of colombia
who is a um construction magnate
goes um hey you should you know i'm now
sitting on
some of the most prime real estate in
bogota
do you fancy putting up a um a
development here and of course he goes
god yeah um and they build what is
called as tower 85
because it's on the 85 block of of
bogota
it's an emblematic development huge
um and uh and so memo phantasma gets
into bed with alvaro rincon who is the
vice president's husband
um and the other well the major
shareholder of that company itos urbanos
was the current vice president and of
course the question is did she or did
she not know
who she was getting into bed with um
[Music]
and anyway i spoke to her i interviewed
her as part of the process i interviewed
her husband as part of the process
he said yeah we did the business deal
with him which they couldn't deny
because i had all the papers
um but they said we had no idea he was a
drug trafficker he had no
arrest warrant which he didn't um and
so you know you know why are you
accusing us of irregular activity
to which of course i replied so this guy
comes in off the street
um he's not from um uh bogota he's from
medellin
um and uh this is
the late 1990s in colombia
you don't think to do any due diligence
on him and so they say yes we did and we
rang
the chief of police to check if this guy
had any record
so i spoke to the chief of police and he
said i don't remember that but it could
have happened
so he was he really hedged himself he
said people are always ringing me to
check and yeah of course i'm sure she
could have done
because she was then the defense
minister um so
you know probably um
but uh yeah it didn't it doesn't smell
right to me
and um uh uh
something happened but memoir not only
does this amazing development but he
gets his children
into the eaton of bogota
or the eaton of colombia but his
children go to the top school
in the country where there's a list
where there's a line going around the
block to get into the school
somehow an outsider gets into this
school
apparently someone wrote a letter on his
behalf
and that person might have been the
colombian vice president because if
you're going to get into the eaton of
columbia you probably need a reference
from someone like that
um so he suddenly is driving around
bortha
like a businessman in his european suits
legit
um legit with his daughter um
his daughters uh in this exclusive
school one of his daughters now
international
um show jumper um you know represents
yeah exactly um uh living in
you know the richest part of the city
and he's clean
but chris he disappears to
madrid in 2015
which is when i find that when that
article is published
which i said which i remember first one
which which which says that memo
fantasma and sebastian colmenares are
the same person
and i don't find that a coincidence um
you know this article is published by a
spanish by a colombian newspaper
saying look at this guy um you know
he's he's these two people but they
don't have a name well they do have a
name and it's the wrong
name because it's the name that he
planted
but he knows that someone's now looking
for him
and so he disappears off and sets up um
a multi-million euro business in madrid
moves his family there puts them into
a really good school in madrid
has a lovely flat in the center of
madrid and a lovely house on the
outskirts of madrid
and he's living the life until i arrive
and knock on the door he's now
sold all his spanish properties
um and he's back in bogota
wow so talk me through flying out
to madrid and how you find where he is
and then you end up
giving him a casual chat yeah
well i didn't he wouldn't see me what
what i did was um
i staked out uh i've got two addresses
because we follow the money
and we see that this company he sets up
two companies in madrid
um under his name so you know i'm able
to follow the companies
and we're able to see what resources he
bought
through those companies so he's bought
this flat he's bought this house
he's got a um a land rover he's got a
bmw motorbike so we've got all this
stuff
um but again he's so clever
um the apartment uh has a um
a porter downstairs so you can't door
step
and the apartment has got two exits one
is the car
exit and one is the the foot exit and
you can't cover them both at once at
least not if you're a poor journalist
with just
you um and then the house is in one of
those close neighborhoods
you know apparently there's lots of real
madrid and all these other
you know it's a very popular closed
neighborhood for those who don't want to
be photographed
and so i can't ambush him there
and so uh i create a ruckus by going
well i go to the apartment and to the
house and um uh
and he's he's in the house i think when
i call
because the the the guard says there's a
guy here wants to speak to
to senor guillermo and i can hear a male
voice
through the the the intercom um and then
the the the guard goes oh no he's not at
home
um but then i go to the his lawyer's
office because again the company has the
lawyer
um and so i go to the lawyer's office
um and i say look i'd like to leave a
message for
guillermo and they go sure um
uh and then i say you know would it be
possible for
for you to give him a call because it's
really quite urgent and just just let
him know that i'm here
um and see if he wants to speak to me
and so they call
and then they come back into the room
and everything is completely changed you
need to leave now
we don't work for kidama cerveda we're
not taking
any any uh message for him
and so i then start screaming um you
know
this company works for terrorists and
drug traffickers
is that what you do uh you know i'm
gonna have to write an article on you
guys are you facilitators for the
underworld
um and i get thrown out um
but the point is of course that he now
knows
that i'm here i've now created a scene
at
his lawyers and the lawyers obviously
didn't know
um and so he rings me
and he goes you know what the hell is
going on how dare you
create all this thing did you threaten
the lawyers how dare you threaten
lawyers
and i said well actually i was here to
threaten you not the lawyers
um and so we have this conversation for
22 minutes
where um he
uh seeks to persuade me that he's not
sebastian colmenares or memor fantasma
um and that i'm some poor gringo
um foreign uh journalist who's been led
astray by various underworld
sources but through the conversation
i am mentioning the names and aliases of
underworld figures that no one should
know
and he clearly knows because he never
questions me once as to who the hell is
don berna or who the hell is um
and so at the end of it he's obviously
flatly denied that he is memo phantasma
but he has convinced me beyond belief
uh any kind of doubt that he is he is um
memo fantasma
uh but he still thinks he can persuade
me so
um he says i'll contact you by email and
i will answer any questions you have but
he never did
he did come to me by email but he never
answered any questions
and then what i kept doing to try and
provoke response is i would send him a
an email going is it true that you were
involved in the killing of
of julio fierro and he would write back
that's outrageous i'm not a
you know i never involved in killing
anyone which was enough for me to keep
you know
getting uh something which we used in
the in the articles
um and um and then there we are
he's won he's still out there and um
and uh he is still um enjoying his
fortune
okay so how did you come to be sued by
the vice president of colombia
okay well after the publication of the
articles
when was that last year that was march
last
year yeah yeah um
uh there's a you know it's on the front
page of all the newspapers in colombia
and uh she's called by every radio and
tv program to
to uh to explain
um and so she sends
me uh via a lawyer a cease and desist
um and then you must rectify um
which i refuse to do i said i'm not
gonna change a comma
in this everything is stood up there is
all the documentation which is included
in the articles if you see
and so i refuse um and so
colombia is one of the few nations on
earth which has
criminal libel because most most cases
are just civil libel whereby
if i call chris williamson an idiot and
say you know
he's a drug trafficker you can prove
you're not a drug trafficker and then i
have to pay you
um a a fine because i have libeled you
well in colombia they have criminal
libel
they also have the civil libel there's
criminal libel which is this person has
with criminal intent set out to blacken
my name
and therefore it's criminal charge and
it comes with a criminal sentence which
is up to 72 months in prison which is
five years
now the reason that everybody all the
bad guys use the criminal
libel is not only because it comes with
a prison sentence
but they don't have to prove that
it's a lie so
if they say if memoir or the vice
president had sued me in civil court
to say you're you're lying to me i would
go
prove it here's the stuff i've said
prove it's not true
which they can't do because i've got all
the documentary evidence
but in the criminal case they don't what
do they have to prove
they don't have to prove anything so
what's the point of
having the criminal libel because what
it does is it passes it to
the attorney general's office and the
attorney general's office
has to investigate it because it's a
criminal report
now the attorney general now has to
decide whether there is a criminal case
to answer
and then it goes to trial or it doesn't
go to trial
the thing that we are worried about or i
am worried about is
it is going to go to trial because he
has some people in the attorney
general's office
however i do not believe that colombia
wants to imprison a british journalist
who has investigated who is being sued
by a colombian drug trafficker who's
already been identified by the attorney
general because that is a public
relations nightmare for colombia
but that doesn't mean that the judicial
process
cannot go go forward
my aim is obviously to make it as high
profile as possible
so that they can't do any manipulation
of
evidence in case or if they do i can go
screaming
you know how can i what what crime have
i
committed um so that's that's where we
are
am i worried about spending five years
in prison i'm not
am i worried about it going to court i
am
um and uh is he trying to
um is he hoping that it's going to cost
me so much money
that i will you know back away
um maybe he is but now
i have pro bono lawyers now who have
taken on the case
um because they think it's as outrageous
as i do so he's not going to be able to
outspend me
either so it's difficult to outspend
someone that's getting stuff for free
exactly um although i think there will
come a point where
my pro bono lawyers might go you know
what we just thought this was on for a
bit of a laugh we didn't realize you
know
three years later that we're still
having to defend you but
we'll we'll see and of course um we're
going to continue publishing and so
i think the next round of articles which
are pretty damning
and has got have got so much detail from
these these inside sources
um are going to do one of two things um
the first is the colombian attorney
general's office is going to be so
embarrassed
that they're actually going to issue an
arrest warrant which is what i'm hoping
is going to happen
or he's going to go on the run again
because at the moment he's living
as we say in spanish como pedro
that's where he left to spain he was
living in bogota as i told you you know
in the top school and yeah
and then he's gone to spain so why come
back
because we were speaking to the guardian
in spain when we were looking on
information for him and he doesn't have
as many people in there he doesn't think
he's quite
protected he doesn't have and the guard
de seville wanted his money
because they wanted to freeze his
accounts um
because there was you know at least 11
million euros in there and they thought
we'll have a bit of that
but again the colombia they needed
documentation from the colombian
attorney general's office which they
didn't get
why didn't they get it they made an
official request
but memo knows somehow about it all he's
flogged everything it seems
and he's left and pulled all of his
money out all of his euros are gone
all this money yeah and now the guard of
the seville uh
you know i spoke to my contact a few
months back and he said yeah the flat
sold
the house is on the market and he's gone
no money for you spanish people and then
yeah and then i found he was in
he was in uh bogota and then he came to
medellin
his mom lives um about uh 800 meters
from my house
in medellin um i can't sorry i need
jeremy why i can't wrap my head around
the fact
that this is superstar underworld
invisible drug lord lawsuits
someone that's by your own definition
criminally insane he's
killing people with primarily insane
criminally saying okay yeah yeah
killing people with surgical precision
obviously very little
um recourse or fear about doing anything
to anyone and you live 800 meters from
his mum
he's in the same place i can't get my
head around
how i mean you've said am i worried
about going to jail no
am i worried about going to court
slightly
at no point have you said worried about
perhaps being killed
yeah and and i had a a long chat with a
couple of underworld sources about
whether he would be the sort of chap
who would would would go down that route
and one source said yeah you'll probably
have an accident someone will try to rob
you except they're not really there to
rob you and you'll get killed in the
attempt
and that's how it'll happen um but then
uh
another all the others including this
source
said no he's not that stupid
because he knows that once you kill an
international journalist
that everybody's gonna run for cover
your dea guys will run for cover your
political protection will run for color
um and they'll there'll be no way and
also
chris he's not gonna sue me and kill me
i really think that's the one or the
other situation here
you know and so i should be slightly
relieved that he's suing me i guess
the vice president what was the
comeuppance of the
criminal case by her she just dropped it
but then didn't she step down as well no
she didn't oh so she's still in office
oh yeah and she's the foreign minister
as well
and she may be running for the
presidency next year but probably not
now
because of what you've i mean in part
it's all my own work but it's not i know
she's been involved in a series of
scandals
um her brother was convicted of drug
trafficking
um and uh and yeah there's all sorts of
other stuff and she's not been a
particularly
competent um vice president so
so she's busy she's got lots of other
stuff to do you can't you can't
run a facilitate a criminal underworld
and repurpose real estate in the heart
of a big city
if you've got a job to do sorting out
politics it gets in the way
to be fair to her um and i i should be
um you know she was never there was
never any proof that she was hands-on on
criminal activity
absolutely never any suggestion her
husband
is a different matter but she no i've
never found anything
to say that she has actively
you know helped drug traffickers remain
off the radar or that sort of thing the
only thing
that we had proven was memo fantasma
laundered
millions of dollars through this
construction
and he still to this day has a lot of
offices in the tower 85
and a lot of the shops at the bottom and
it generates him
vast rents every year how is it
that drug lords launder their money
through
real estate because presumably you can't
just pay everyone in cash or can you is
it because there's so many laborers and
contractors
that you can just repurpose your
ill-gotten gains that way
well there are several there are several
um loopholes one is um
uh well perhaps the rather than than get
um all um uh technical about this
um there are two things that are really
useful for a drug trafficker and real
estate
one is what which is what memor did he
um he buys land
okay and then he makes a deal with the
construction company
to say i'm gonna give you this land and
then you're gonna give me
15 offices 50 parking spaces and three
of the shops
and so the constructor goes okay so he
doesn't appear
in the construction so
you know when they're building it memo
phantasma's name was nowhere
because there was just a a deal signed
and we've managed to get it from the
notary between
him and the company to say we're going
to give you this bit of land
and you're going to give us the stuff
afterwards so but how that appears from
outside
is suddenly he is the legal owner
of 15 offices 40 parking spaces and
five shops and it's legal
you know he hasn't put 50 million in
drug money into a bank and into a
construction company
he has simply got the titles now of
these so nothing's gone through the bank
because you know if you put ten thousand
dollars in a bank
you know they're supposed to be a red
flag um well of course in this system
there are no red flags
he had to buy the land which he did in
his mom's name and the company's name
and it was you know he did it over
several months and it didn't raise any
any red flags um
but he didn't sell that money and then
give it to the construction company and
then no no
there's this back back door deal done
and then the other thing
which he which memo did is
he's the proud owner now of 15 offices
he then pays his drug debts
by giving the titles of tea to of these
offices
to various of his people so
they are now his drug debts are all paid
no money has changed hands
and the the people um
have now got a nice shiny title and of
course what isn't happening is no one's
looking at the buying and selling of
every property
to see if it's dodgy or not they're just
looking at banks
is is there money moving around that
can't be justified but if i
jeremy mcdermott give chris williams an
office williamson
office the you know the attorney general
and the police aren't really going to
look at that are they
they're just going to see that an office
has changed hands
even the long term that office might
generate half a million pounds a year or
something like that
absolutely in terms of rent it is you
know and and the rent has to be declared
but that's the beauty of it because now
he's declaring money that he can then go
on to spend
legitimately that he can now go on to
spend and memo owns
many different buildings uh and
properties in bogota now
and then we reckon he makes up to two
million dollars
a year just from the rents on these
properties
which is awesome yeah legit spend it on
a car buy a house with it go on holiday
with it
well you know you can live on two
million surely
chris depends on how many show jumping
ponies the
the daughter needs us that that is true
but um
i still think you know there's a there's
some wiggle room there for a good legit
life
um what's happening next you've got this
new set of articles so there's
this set of articles is on insight crime
it'll be linked in the show notes below
if you've
enjoyed this story it goes into so much
more depth you've got all the photos and
the scans of the documents
it's an unbelievable read and now you've
got this
80 hours of underworld interviews and
all of the next stuff
and that's what's coming out next
another series of articles that's coming
out
yeah it'll be another between four and
six um
articles the reason it's taken so long
is the verification
and then the other is the money we've
really tried to
follow the money um and the reason for
this chris
is that um the drug trafficking is now
so far in the past
that he could get away with it you know
is there a statute of limitations
yeah stuff like that there is if there's
not murder involved
there does seem to be a statute of
limitations which is why the dea
turned around to him and said if you
behave yourself
for the next 10 years these indictments
will disappear
um so on the drug trafficking
um it looks like there's statue of
limitations
um the murders are very hard for us to
prove
but the money he can't hide
um and he has to justify where this 30
million dollars
from a guy who's born into nothing in
medellin has come from and so we think
that this
is the best way to get him
into prison will be where did all this
money come from because
the money laundering every time that
office that he bought with the drug
money
earns money it's money laundering so
there's no statute of limitations
because he's still earning the money on
it
and so we think that's the way you know
it's al capone and the taxes we think
that's the way we'll get him
is through the money it's so crazy
it's so mad to think about how many
other
people are probably in this situation as
well you know this is one guy
that you've managed to track down i
imagine that
there must be many others who've managed
to get to his
sort of status and
it's also such a you know for all that
his
tactics might be nefarious it's a very
admirable
uh shrewd business acumen
understanding of the world and the way
that it works that
you can front load your wealth
acquisition
by trying to get into the position of um
distribution as fast as possible that
you can make some deals to protect
yourself when it happens that you can
have the political allies to ensure that
you stay free
and then once you've front loaded that
wealth you move into legitimate business
and go quiet having removed your past as
fast as possible
to then be this ghost of a person for
10 years 15 years let the indictments go
with the statute of limitations come
back in
remove the money back into the system
and you are now
a relatively functioning member of
society with a bunch of legitimate
business
and status and wealth
just one thing you missed there is i
think he deliberately
went into business with people
who would protect him so like the
husband
i don't think that is coincidence i
think
he's thinking how do i tie in powerful
people
i will give them a deal they can't turn
down so he goes to
the husband and he says listen i'm going
to give you this
prime real estate at a really good deal
he jumps at it
of course he jumps at it but that's it
now he's tied in
and his wife's tied in and we think
we've
done this well and also they don't want
this to come out
they don't want this to come out so they
are now invested
in maintaining his legitimacy
and his legal facade it's brilliant
don't you think it's brilliant
yeah it's a shame that he applied his
talents to
criminality because you know we'd
probably be living in a
utopia and surfing on mars if he'd
actually managed to apply this talent to
something a bit more
unfortunately and you know i'll put this
to you
chris you have a choice you can
enter the legal world in colombia where
the minimum wage is
two thousand dollars a year and you can
go to school and work your way up
um and you know uh maybe you will earn
uh 500 000 over the course of your life
okay which is what the average columbian
gets nowhere near
or you can move 10
kilos of cocaine just once
and you will earn the same amount as
you're going to earn in your entire
legal existence would you take that
risk chris well i'm a law-abiding
citizen and as you know jeremy we're
both very orderly
we're both very orderly british fellas
we
stick to the rules um yeah i mean
you can see the temptation absolutely
and this also highlights
what often gets brought up to do with
wealth inequality
right that when you have these
disparities in wealth when you have some
people that have a lot and some people
that have
none at all that is one of the um
sparks for crime and it kind of makes
sense
if it's so so much of a grind
to make an amount of money that in
another i i imagine that it's not hard
to get into drugs
if you want to in colombia or in mexico
still today it's not hard to get into
crime
okay that's you know and then you get
into the drug world
um as well but uh yeah the rewards are
so
high and what memo the reason that memo
phantasm is such an
emblematic figure is that the fact he's
still out there shows that the risks are
sufficiently
low for you to make it worthwhile and
that's the message we have to send
is that he can't get away with it um
and he has so far jeremy mcdermott
ladies and gentlemen
if people want to check out more about
this where should they go
uh please come to uh the insight crime
website um
uh we're a big team of 45 journalists
scattered around latin america and the
caribbean we do organize
crime day in day out please come and
visit
awesome thanks so much for today cheers
chris
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace